[Musique]
il ya aujourd'hui quatre cents ans la
reine et ciao régné d'une main de fer
sur le puissant royaume de langkasuka
appelait alors le royaume des trois
reines aux côtés de ses soeurs mais les
pays voisins les rebelles et les pirates
convoitait ses richesses et rêvait
d'envahir langkasuka en 1593 le maître
d'armes hollandais john hicks prix se
rendit alors qu'à suzuka avec son
apprenti chinois le grand inventeur lim
kim
il venait remettre les grands canons que
la reine leur avait commandé pour
défendre son royaume
mais leur bateau fut attaqué par les
pirates de l'infâme corbeau noir un
flibustier expert en sorcellerie doom
qui allie les arts martiaux à la magie
noire corbeaux noirs ne puisse s'emparer
des canons
le bateau explosa emportant avec lui
janice prix les canons ont disparu au
fond de la mer
[Musique]
mais je dois
c'est bizarre on questionne qu'il fait
tu verras laissons essayé essayé
non tu es trop petit je voulais moi
aussi
et en plus je suis plus léger tout je ne
prendrait pas ce risque
et tu sais que ton oncle anjar me
tuerait s'il t'arrivait quoi que ce soit
ton oncle et terrifiant il est plus
terrifiant quelqu'un allait aider moi
soulevé seul s'il vous plaît les enfants
regarde le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez vu l'oiseau a perdu neige
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
les enfants j'espère que cette fois vous
ne vous moquerez pas de moi j'ai une
nouvelle invention qu'est ce que c'est
cette fois j'ai surnommé ça le nahd vite
énergie c'est ça les enfants
grâce à cette invention vous nagerez
comme des petits poissons vous ne
trouvez pas ça ingénieux vous voulez
essayer
alors venez avec moi oui on adore ça
[Musique]
biltong tu as l'air triste attends tu
habites loyer pour toi en fond de la mer
tu sais tiens
[Musique]
majesté voici les honorables émissaire
du japon
[Musique]
zhang que fais tu ici père vous allez
trop fiers de votre fils unique
j'ai remporté le concours de la garde
royale vous qui habitez ayutthaya depuis
tant d'années maintenant je suis remplit
d'orgueil
tu es très jeune mais tu as déjà une
brillante carrière
ta mère serait très fière de toi je te
rassure pour moi vers servir langkasuka
est le plus grand des honneurs
nous travaillerons ensemble majesté les
honorables émissaire d'aden tiennent à
vous saluer
majesté mettez vous à l'abri
on est les deux à ce titre
[Musique]
au débit lent
là
[Musique]
ah ah
non
[Musique]
il
un camp landja pour amener dans quelle
direction
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'était que ça
paris
allons
reste à côté de moi
haha
il n'y a rien
anjar
non
paris salue notre maître comme il se
doit
c'est le fils d'un russe n'est ce pas il
s'appelle paris la femme du pauvre
aarhus non je sais anjar pourquoi
l'avoir conduit jusqu'à moi pour vous
prier de l'initier aux douloureux chien
m
pas
il a des traits communs avec vous il est
né au milieu de l'océan est il et
ventriloque cela importe peu anjar
louloum n'est pas fait pour tuer
j'imagine que tu vas en faire un
guerrier
qu'as-tu encore en tête corbeau noir
sévit toujours et nous devons l'arrêté m
vous savez que nous ne pouvons plus
accepter sa tyrannie
si tutu corbeau noir
tôt ou tard un autre prendra sa place
mais je anjar je te conseille d'oublier
cette vengeance
tu dois lui apprendre l'amour enseigne
lui les bases du doom enseigne lui à
vivre de la pêche à fonder une famille
m je t'écoute j'ai entendu un hurlement
tout à l'heure sur le bateau c'était le
cri des ténèbres les ténèbres et
unibroue peuvent crier
oui si tu pratiques le doom le coeur
rempli de haine alors les forces des
ténèbres hurleront en toi mon enfant est
rien moi bien puisque ray blanche refuse
de le faire c'est moi qui te prendrais
lit le vieillard m'a dit que les
ténèbres hurleront moi je suis plus très
sûr d'en avoir envie de savoir te sera
bénéfique crois moi elle te servira à
lutter contre ton ennemi qui est mon
ennemi corbeau noir
heureusement nos remèdes ont pu retenir
la propagation du poison
mais pour ce qui est de ses cicatrices
je crains hélas qu'on ne puisse rien
faire ça ne fait rien tant que mon fils
est vivant je m'estime heureux
la reine est arrivée
[Musique]
ne vous en faites pas il est sauvé le
pays est redevable envers votre fils
notre armée peut-être fier de le compter
dans ses rangs
son sacrifice ne sera pas vain
le prince rawa et nous payera cet
affront je vous le jure
[Musique]
ledoux lung compte neuf niveaux
inférieurs et trois niveaux supérieurs
tu devras assimilés progressivement ses
enseignements
les trois premiers niveaux que nous
allons étudier t'aideront à distinguer
le son des différents poissons et à
devenir capable de sentir la force des
éléments le temps la température
l'humidité les courants et les vents tu
sentiras grâce au douloureux le lien
entre les poissons et le climat et tu
liras dans leurs pensées
tu prédira les courants et repéra les
bancs de poissons et indiqueront aussi
l'arrivée de la pluie grâce aux trois
niveaux suivants tu pourras produire un
son particulier pour donner certains
ordres créatures de l'océan comme celui
d'attac et tes ennemis
ton esprit sera totalement lié aux leurs
[Musique]
mais pour communiquer avec ses créatures
il te faudra être patient pour cela il
te faudra maîtriser les échelons
supérieurs et seul raies blanches pour
atteler enseigné en temps voulu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
le banc de poissons se trouve juste en
dessous de nos patients sont plaints de
jar binks j'ai un cadeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
je dis attention sur le bon
[Musique]
paris heureusement que tu étais là ils
auraient pu me tuer
merci de m'avoir sauvé un instant c'est
toi qui a bâti c'est trop de
l'embarcation qui ont wii ainsi que
toutes les armes que tu vois c'est moi
qui les ai fabriqués notre inventeur à
tous fabriqués en secret maintenant tu
sais tout nous voulons piéger les
pirates de corbeaux noirs
mais la tâche est ardue nous
n'arriverons pas approcher ce traître et
moi je vais me joindre à vous d'ici peu
nous réussirons à éliminer toute cette
vermine vous verrais plutôt que tu ne le
croit
nous ferons d'une pierre deux coups
bientôt le royaume de langues à son cas
sur un autre vous avez une idée mon
prince les grands canons se trouve au
fin fond des profondeurs de l'océan
difficile de les récupérer mais nous
pouvons renforcer nos rangs réunissant
nos forces
plus d'un pirate nous suivra dans la
conquête du royaume il nous suffit de
chercher nos alliés prince qu'est ce qui
vous fait croire que les autres pirates
se joindront à nous
[Musique]
apparemment langue asuka est incapable
de produire de puissants canon pour se
défendre de ses ennemis
alors que le pays fait la convoitise de
ses voisins
nous devons à nouveau chercher un
fabricant de canon pour assurer notre
défense renzaho vaut aller vite en
besogne
pourquoi ton de vad notre royaume n'est
pas en guerre chirat chica dire votre
candeur me surprendra toujours en que le
prince rawa et sera vivant nous devons
rester sur nos gardes
mais langue que son cas est vaste c'est
un royaume béni des dieux
alors il doit bien exister un fabricant
de canon quelque part sur nos terres
toucs rahmane vous désirez parler
j'ignore si c'est vrai mais quelqu'un
m'a dit il y à peu que l'apprenti
chinois de janis bris vivre est ici
vraiment quel est son new line ku
comment savez-vous ce la gelée sud il ya
quelques jours ici même chez à rennes je
dînais avec l'émissaire hollandais et à
la fin du repas le bougre et est ivre il
m'a confessé avoir survécu à l'attaqué
du bateau qui transportait les grands
canons que vous aviez commander tout
autant que l'hymne ku marraine et selon
l'émissaire il vivrait aller dans un
village de pêcheurs à l'ouest
alors trouvé l'hymne qm au plus vite
s'il fait partie des rebelles alors vous
devrez le tuer il ne sera d'aucune aide
et s'ils refusent de coopérer vous
devrez le tuer également
[Musique]
hung où je dois t'avouer que je plains
son futur mari du manie l'art que comme
un garçon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel talent prince et son goût vous
faites honneur à votre réputation
qui êtes vous comment osez vous entrez
dans le palais de la sorte je suis
l'invité de votre reine et pour la
remercier de son hospitalité vous
interrompez notre entraînement je m'en
excuse
quel est votre nom je m'appelle abdul
ghafoor moai dean le prince de bang
bongo
dans deux jours se tiendront des
fiançailles et tu seras marier l'année
prochaine
qui voudrait d'une fiancée qui se
promène avec une arbalète sous le bras
je n'ai aucune envie de me marier
sache que le prince de pahang est arrivé
et s'il te voit ainsi il va vite changer
d'avis il a déjà vu un goût oui et je
lui ai tenu tête hung où tu dois cesser
ces enfantillages langkasuka ne compte
que peu d'alliés pour cette raison le
soutien de parents gays et essentiel
c'est pour notre royaume que je dois me
sacrifier le seigneur n'accorderait
tamara elle sultan oncle à se prépare à
nous attaquer depuis des jours
quant au prince sera ouailles il
complote avec corbeau noir et avec tous
les pirates les ennemis entourent
langkasuka dois je le rappeler tous les
jours de la semaine
[Musique]
et
où
félicitations seigneur 22 vire la
compagnie des indes orientales est en
pleine expansion et on m'a dit que ses
activités se développer à toute vitesse
je suis infiniment reconnaissant envers
votre royaume
mais j'avoue que l'activité commerciale
de la région connaîtrait une croissance
bien plus forte
si les hollandais en avait l'exclusivité
m'ajuster seigneur van der veer votre
repas serait bien fade si vous deviez le
déguster seul n'est ce pas
je suis ravi de vous revoir votre
chambre et elle confortable tout à fait
merci de votre hospitalité vous nous
recevez toujours avec tant d'amitié
princesse bureau je vous présente pas
demoiselle lan fille d'un marchand
illustres de la région de wenzhou
elle est venue de chine jusqu'à votre
royaume mademoiselle lane
[Musique]
c'est votre premier séjour à langkasuka
onesta oui votre majesté mon frère vit
dans votre grand royaume
je suis venu le retrouver votre frère
habite ici effectivement princesse biron
cela fait des années qu'il vit sur vos
terres il s'appelle l'hymne cube
l'apprenti de janis prix je vois que
vous le connaissez je suis venu lui
demander de rentrer en chine
j'ai promis à ma mère de le ramener je
ne rentrerai pas sans lui
j'étais envie de le revoir nous
voudrions aussi voir votre frère voyez
vous un inconvénient à ce que nous vous
accompagnons mademoiselle ce serait un
grand honneur
[Musique]
quoi
des nouvelles du royaume la reine aurait
retrouvé l'expert en canon il y aurait
eu donc plus d'un survivant l'attaquent
vos craintes étaient justifiées mais il
y à plus grave encore d'ici quelques
jours
lang assouka sera unia pang si les deux
royaumes finissent par s'unir
notre tâche n'en sera que plus ardue
croyais je crois qu'il est temps de
prouver à la reine qui nous sommes bien
plus nombreux qu elle ne pense mais à
qui confier cette mission
nous devrions voir cela avec les
japonais les waco
[Musique]
non
alors sortez fait du prince
[Musique]
pardon presque là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez
[Applaudissements]
non
paris maintenant je n'appartiens plus
qu'à toi
[Musique]
majesté je vous présente les mystères de
sangkhla
[Musique]
et voici le seigneur phare où ce mot
roule émissaire de son clan
[Musique]
le sultan souleymane vous envoie à ceux
présents
[Musique]
majesté voici le seigneur aride famille
émissaires du royaume de jao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
fouiller le bateau
j'irai voir à l'intérieur
on
[Musique]
enjoy
voilà
ok
tort aux tirs au but
lâchez-moi là c'est moi ça le sauvage
dans tout l'est la star du lait ou je te
le dieu qu'est-ce que c'est camille ban
attend de moi vous canon jamais hors de
question jalal en terre
non
oh
attends à l'est pas tant
audiard ok ok haha
oh
bintang
pétanque
[Musique]
et toc
je vous présente mes plus sincères
excuses j'ai dû envoyer birou young ou
en mission urgente sheikh abdul elles
n'ont pas pu vous dire au revoir je vous
informerai de la date du mariage soyez
en assurés mais pour l'heure rester ici
c'est un honneur de vous recevoir
c'est gentil à vous majesté mais je vais
rentrer la mousson approche au revoir
saluer votre soeur de ma part il me
tarde déjà de la revoir
vous pouvez être fiers de votre fils
c'est un valeureux guerrier c'est un
privilège que de l'entendre de votre
bouche
à gatineau
voilà ce qui arrive quand on implique de
pauvres innocents mais je ne vais pas
m'en plaindre parce que grâce à toi j'ai
pu goûter aux filles de ton village leur
beauté et déroutante défi délicieuse
savoureuse yamgname
joli c'est un enfer que tu retrouveras
ta femme
en
princesse
il n'y a plus personne je ne vois qu'un
seul blessé et les corps ne sont pas
ceux des villageois qui vivent ici
l'âne regard des cimes survivants et
votre frère
[Musique]
mon
vous
[Musique]
paris
que les dieux pardonne mon arrogance
toutes ces années j'ai cherché à venger
mon maître hollandais
jamais je n'aurais imaginé que mon
orgueil allait engendrer la mort de mes
frères je n'arrive à penser à rien
d'autre
je me sens si coupable le chasseur au
nom du royaume je compatis mais m
l'hymne ces gens ne seront pas morts en
vain
si vous acceptez de construire un
puissant canon pour défendre notre pays
cela fait bien longtemps que je me suis
rangé de votre côté jeu et corbeaux
noirs autant que jour j'ai bien assez de
sang sur les mains je ne peux rien faire
de plus vous devriez y réfléchir car si
vous refusez de nous aider vous et votre
soeur je vous ferai raccompagné jusqu'en
chine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle surprise
voilà une prise de premier choix
quelle ardeur vous devriez être honorée
de m'avoir pour escorte
prenez les et conduisait les bateaux
pitt
emmenez les plus vite vite
[Musique]
allez faites et les cendres
on
[Musique]
allez lève toi
je tenais au cachot vite
thomas mon frère guillaume
diaw
wei
qui êtes vous je suis zhang soldats de
l'anp gasu cas
à
remercie
mais qui est tout
c'est vous de la banque
il faut y aller process
paris ma tante
ils feront rien je sais souffre les
autres qui entend vite
nous devons finir un sexe
ils sont juste derrière nous
princesse dépêchez vous on doit attendre
de move on n'a pas le temps il faut y
aller
les flèches opposeront la femme n'en
paraît chiens tués je te dirais de mes
propres mains tard en cette soirée morts
marche
c'est bien tard
venir au secours
corbeau noir
[Musique]
voile
elle
at elle s'échappe
bonjour
votre chair est perdu je ne peux pas
vous laisser ici vous ceci
il est là à bâle
[Musique]
très beau livre
quel dommage qu'est ce qui est dommage
je déplore que ton grand sourire et
disparus ainsi que ton enthousiasme
je me souviens de toi quand je t'ai
connu il ya dix ans les yeux pétillaient
il n'en reste plus rien
paris
mon enfant la haine à petit cela n est
que feriez vous à ma place j'ai perdu
tous ceux à qui je tenais si tu n'avais
pas tuer leur zone peut-être qu'il
n'aurait pas tué sa femme morte où tu
dois leur pardonner maintenant tu dois
essayer d'arrêter cette spirale de
violence paris si tu veux à l'avenir
comprendre la fragilité de la vie cela
ne me ramènera ni ma femme ligne un
pauvre anjar ils ont tué lui aussi
je ne ressens que de la colère
tu doit laver ton esprit et facettés
peur pour retrouver la quiétude
la colère est une funeste conseillère à
leur chasse l'acton esprits
nous nous trouvons nous vous êtes chez
moi sur l'île de ré blanche
vous croyez vous allez je veux rentrer à
mende cassou cas pour l'instant vous
allez devoir rester ici pourquoi ça
parce que vous finiriez en pâture pour
les poissons si vous partiez c'est la
mousson les vents et les vagues sont
terribles prenez la mer et vous ne
survivrez pas
birou pérou qu'est-il arrivé tu es
blessé
je vais bien mais on goût que lui est-il
arrivé
je n'ai pu protéger votre soeur ou goût
majesté en guise de châtiment je vous
offre ma vie vous vérifiez de votre
mieux carangues langue à son caveau est
encore plus redevable je trouverais
l'espion qui a causé la mort de ma soeur
un pauvre seront goût je jure que je te
mangerais je finirai par trouver celui
qui est entraînée dans l'eau demain
[Rires]
qui êtes vous que faites vous ici je te
retourne la question qui es tu je suis
paris mais moi je suis raynouard
raynouard vous avez un lien avec ray
blanche
c'est lui qui m'a enfermée dans les
ténèbres
nous sommes semblables pourtant voiture
j'imagine que c'est ton m il refuse de
m'enseigner il pense que mon coeur est
rempli de colère et de rancune
on n'éprouve jamais trop de colère dans
la vie je serai ton maître s'il refuse
de l'enseigné
la colère peut faire plus que l'amour
l'hymne tube tu détiens toutes les
réponses que j'attendais
tu tiens énormément à ta soeur
semble-t-il aide nous à construire un
canot je te laisse y réfléchir jusqu'à
la fin de la mousson
bloque sa respiration abdominale
et en voilà dans ton corps
[Musique]
où
mais où
[Musique]
à
paris tu es le meilleur disciple que je
n'ai jamais eu plus la colère te
remplira plus vite tu apprendras
on
oui donc
huit angles
une tank paris du futur donc lâche moi
tant que
lâchement tank
paris la force obscure s'est emparé de
ton âme n'oublie pas les heureuses
penser
bongo ne lui en tient pas rigueur
lamarre est forte elle seule peut
perturber les sorciers de l'omh
attendons la mer se retire et avec elle
les ténèbres son esprit s'est assombri
avec la marée le désir devient
incontrôlable
regardez le le doom et maléfique
je me sens déjà mieux
ledoux loum est une arme à double
tranchant il faut l'utiliser à bon
escient paris fréquenté raynouard ne
t'apportera que la peine mon enfant est
vite le ou tu deviendras comme corbeau
noir au pire encore comme raynouard
pourquoi l'avez vous enfermer dans les
ténèbres
il ne fait que semer le mal et la colère
sur terre je ne pouvais pas le laisser
en liberté
qu'at-il fait au juste c'était un
combattant voué à un brillant avenir
un homme droit et intrépide c'est ainsi
qu'il est devenu ministre de la guerre
mais il avait une liaison avec une des
concubines du roi
une nuit il s'empara du poignard du
prince bima et assassinat le roi c'est
ce qui permit au prince round de devenir
roi par la suite
je le tuerai je tuerai avec son propre
poignard
[Musique]
dépêche toi
tiens
[Musique]
tu l'as fait exprès
par maintenant je ne veux pas que ta
colère m'habite
courage blanche résister
[Musique]
vous rendez vous compte
même le maître plient devant le
douloureux noir on goût pardonnez moi
pour l'autre nuit je n'étais plus
moi-même
ça n'est rien vous m'avez embrasser ce
sans même m'en demander la permission
je dois vous confesser que vous m'avez
fait très peur je voulais juste
c'est terminé ne vous en faites pas
vous voyez cette grotte je les creuser
dans le but de me enfermé lorsque mes
forces m'abandonne tous sortis à des
moments de faiblesse et c'est parfois au
désir enfoui au tréfonds de son âme
mais lorsqu'il perd le contrôle
le sorcier peut chavirer dans la nuit
parfois quand je sens que les forces des
ténèbres sont sur le point de me
posséder mais j'utilise un sort pour me
faufiler dans la grotte par une fissure
et je n'en ressort que quand j'ai repris
mes esprits
paris tu ne me laisse pas vraiment le
choix
dès demain je t'apprendrai le double
blanc le temps est venu de canaliser
toute cette énergie qui te rends toi
merci m qu'as tu à dire pour sa défense
grand rail
si vous me tuez vous perdrez tout mais
si vous libérer ma soeur je vous aiderai
lan ou spa imbécile je ne pense pas que
ce soit vraiment position négocier
tu sais ce qu'il arriverait ta soeur si
le canon marche pas dans les jours qui
viennent à ta place je ne jouerai plus
de vilains tours tu tiens ta soeur
attendez laissez là partir je vous
aiderai vous aurez vos canons mais ils
ne seront jamais à la hauteur de ceux de
janis prix
emmenez-le art et lurgi nous aurons nos
canons nous devons retrouver notre
maître maintenant
[Musique]
la magie d'houlouve consiste à associer
la force de l'homme à celle des poissons
tout être vivant à des désirs pour les
poissons
c'est la nourriture pour les hommes la
luxure le pouvoir la haine
l'avidité et la vengeance
[Musique]
marraine pour rejoindre l'île du corbeau
noir il n'y a qu'un seul accès un chenal
[Musique]
il est entouré d'une paroisse de rochers
ce qui pourrait jouer peut-être en notre
avantage il sera ainsi plus facile de
les piéger leurs forteresses deviendra
leur prison mais avant toute chose nous
devons sauver limpio message sur la
n'avons que corbeaux noirs ne l'obligent
à fabriquer un canon merci jack lang je
considérerais vous remarque que l'on
prépare tout de suite en bataillon nous
les attaquerons dès que le vent tombera
bien ajusté si ensemble nous collaborons
nous pourrons conquérir le royaume de
langue à souk à cette fois quand comptez
vous attaquez unir nos forces prendra un
certain temps
j'aurais bien peur imaginez le temps
qu'il vous faudra seulement pour réunir
les mercenaires de macassar nous
entraînerons nos soldats lors de la
mousson et ensuite au dixième mois
nous lancerons l'offensive lanka souka
ne résistera pas oui ça fait longtemps
que je rêve aux richesses de l'anc
assouka
nous les javanais nous ne sommes pas
nombreux mais nous avons deux valeureux
guerriers en échange nous espérons
recevoir notre dû bien évidemment
le vent nos verres
à la gloire des pirates à la gloire des
pirates
les deux canons que je fabrique sont
destinés à lanka souka le royaume de
badoo ça nous a été d'une grande aide
j'offrirai mes meilleurs canon à sa
majesté assesseurs pour qu'elles
puissent assurer la protection de leur
pays
il en va de ma réputation n'oublie pas
l'hymne qm savoir montrer sa gratitude
est une des choses les plus importantes
dans la vie
le cannois a été conçu afin d'avoir une
grande portée m
quant aux canons b aucun canon n'est
plus dévastateur ils sont
impressionnants vous verrez tu te
contentes de peu imaginent ce qui
pourrait arriver si on combine et leurs
caractéristiques
m
à
[Musique]
non
à
[Musique]
oh
lorsque paris réussir à maîtriser le
sixième niveau
la mission sera terminée s'il veut se
perfectionner
alors il devra le faire tout seul
[Musique]
et
je n'ai pas vu les blanches depuis des
jours il est temps de partir vers
langkasuka
on a passé de bons moments ici séjour
sur l'île m'ont beaucoup appris
bongo si je pouvais je resterai ici à
jamais
[Musique]
moi aussi
mais je dois rentrer au palais on doit
me croire morte
[Musique]
jamais tu mourras
car aussi longtemps que je vivrai
[Musique]
tu vivras quelque part dans mon coeur
on goût nous devons quitter l'île
[Musique]
tu ferais
je ne permet jamais vu sourire encore
[Musique]
jha ring le père de jharkhand doit
partir pour pas rendre dès aujourd'hui
bien il pourra peut-être convaincre le
prince de comprendre notre situation
voyant s'il peut lui prêter main forte
je dois partir majesté je suis venu vous
faire mes adieux
trente deux mille hommes sont prêts à
attaquer lille ils seront mutés
alors que la chance vous accompagne tout
le royaume compte sur votre et zhang je
vous remercie de votre confiance il
défendrait le royaume de l'anc assouka
jusqu'à la mort
chittagong soyez prudents
ton canaux est il prêt que vas-tu encore
inventé pour tuer pourquoi as tu accepté
de le construire ne me regarde pas comme
ça s'il te plaît tu dois me croire je
n'avais pas le choix
le chauffe moi je n'ai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans ce fameux experts langage tout cas
n'est pas capable de construire un tel
canon c'est exact et si l'on
construisait un nous en serions informés
par notre espion excellent
[Musique]
cher frère je te tiens dieu
m
[Musique]
placer délicatement les explosifs à
l'extérieur en avant allez
[Musique]
il
allez
à
allez voir dépêchez vous
baa
attention ils nous ont péri
[Musique]
à
non pas toi
[Musique]
mètre cube mètre cube
il faut partir venez
encore toi
[Musique]
paris paris avec paris je t'aime je
t'aime tout le temps
bah c'est sûr le goût comme ans plus
tard allons nous en allons
[Musique]
allez voir par là
non
en mourra ensemble non
attention
mon
[Musique]
vettel ou pas
paris i
[Musique]
m
n
non
[Musique]
très blanche
bah
[Musique]
mon fils j'ai choisi le nom que tu
porteras rails
[Musique]
à
oh
j'sais pas quoi tu veux c est ce que tu
te sens bien je vais bien ce n'est
qu'une éraflure c'est mon coeur qui
souffrent geren notre attaque a affaibli
les nids certes mais nous avons perdu de
nombreux hommes
que voulez vous c'est bien le propre de
la guerre valeureuse garang
vous avez raison mais majesté
les pirates ont de puissants canon une
attaque est à prévoir d'ici plusieurs
jours
il faut que tout cela fut fait foi de
personnes ont sacrifié leur vie pour
lang assouka ni la mort de ma soeur ni
celle de paris ne seront inutiles
princesse l'avenir du royaume dépend de
votre mariage maintenant
tout à fait majesté nous avons besoin de
larmes et de parole
le mariage ne peut plus être repoussée
ne nous at on pas peut-être devrions
nous attendre le retour du conseiller de
jarring avant d'envoyer la princesse à
pargues de toute façon ce mariage de
leurs chants de guerre ce n'est un
secret pour personne n'est ce pas
tu liras en goût il fera ce qu'on lui
dit
je connais mon devoir j'épouserai le
prince de par ang
[Musique]
tu doit coûte que coûte arrêter le cycle
infernal et comprendre la fragilité de
la vie
[Musique]
dépêchez vous pas honte doit préparer
ses noces à l'heure qu'il est
il ne pourra pas envoyer de renforts
prenons le de cours
il n'aura pas de deuxième chance cette
fois langkasuka est à nous
diane aux hommes de quitter l'île et de
mettre immédiatement le cap vert pour
hao wang
nous lèverons lancre ce soir dealer
également qu'ils recevront un cadeau de
mon père
du nerf
pères
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien tout est dit après le mariage ungur
reviendra avec l'armée de pahang pensez
vous qu'ils arriveront à temps j'en suis
convaincu majesté vous les aurez tous
nos hommes y travaillent sans relâche
les deux canons que nous construisons
repousseront l'ennemi un certain temps
vous verrez
néanmoins je suis inquiet continue et je
vous en prie je crains que les pirates
ne soit en train d'essayer de récupérer
les grands canons de mon maître ce n'est
qu'une supposition injuste et nous ne
devons pas céder à la panique mais ne
les sous-estimé pas non plus travailler
corbeaux noirs sont capables de tout
j'ai une stratégie pour repousser leurs
flottes
une stratégie audacieuse certes mais ça
pourrait peut-être marché cher rennes
quelques soldats seront nécessaires à sa
mise en place
[Musique]
r soyez prudents
il
moi quand même
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
mes canons
e
[Musique]
mais canon sont plus prodigieux encore
que ce que janice avait conçu
[Musique]
mais
majesté les pirates approche des
remparts
[Musique]
seniors 40
ils sont plus nombreux que nous dire et
on met de la distance ne laissait pas
débarquer sur nos côtes
[Musique]
nous y voilà canonnier vous êtes prêts
les canaux peuvent être rechargées
pirate attention préparez vous à
débarquer
[Applaudissements]
fait
doubler la puissance de feu
il va falloir viser plus haut bisous
fin
mais c'est vous
que la flotte manalo s'apprête à tirer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chercheur à kew
vous enregistrer
les cadors de guillaume sont ils prêts
dépêchez vous
avancer plus vite
dames
soyez prudent fait attention attention
attention
kate feu tenez vos positions ne voudriez
pas ne vous oublie surtout pas
à 0
plus vite à l'eau
des conditions
à
taha
m
ozawa quotidien prend la relève 40 je
compte sur toi pour l'heure je dois
préparer les armes qui assureront notre
victoire
ce link guillaume est vraiment un génie
la victoire est assurée grâce à lui n'a
cessé pas le feu tu ne sens groupe a
entendu
posez vos armes et me tiens hadji que
faites vous c'était un petit être
conseillés ordonné le cessez-le-feu
je vous conseille de m'obéir marraine où
je vous tue c'est donc vous le traître
l'espion tu nous as trahis
du calme je les fais pour mon neveu
round
j'ai choisi le nom que tu porteras
travail j'ai vu
princesse birrou posez votre épée tout
de suite
qu'attendez vous
dit aux soldats de se tirer tout de
suite au décès
pour le royaume je donnerai ma vie peu
m'importe mourir à les attirer rémy zhao
bien
puisque vous y tenez la reine va mourir
lang à saucats dépend de toi en avant
tuez les tous
[Musique]
non allez des soldats
c'est donc vous l'espion insolent de
leurs ouailles cas vont continuer sur
tout le monde peut occuper pas de moi
quand tu es à tirette
[Musique]
ça
vous
ils les ont trouvés soldats tirer sur ce
bateau
ils sont retrouvés j'ai cru cannois
[Musique]
rémy jo
je
chroniqueur au 9e round
[Musique]
et s'arrêter vous fait pas peur seniors
carangues soldats à vos postes sur le
champ que les dieu protège notre arène
pour notre reine
soldat vous êtes traits tirés
vous
[Musique]
guerrier des vents envolez-vous
bon
mais c'est l'émoi de fusil
mais
fin
non
à la gloire de la reine
[Musique]
feu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non pas fait
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu es devenu maintenant mettre du tout
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
je suis navré père je devais le faire ce
combat doit cesser et la paix doit
régner maintenant tu dois essayer
d'arrêter cette spirale de violence
paris si tu veux à l'avenir comprendre
la fragilité de la vie
hu
[Musique]
à
bah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tara c'est parti
vilaret de l'occident
moi
pas là
agréable
quant aux
c'est en apprenant à se détacher de
toute chose que l'esprit peut s'unir à
la mer mais ne faire qu'un avec elle
elle
arras
à
[Musique]
là
quand
à
[Musique]
ah ah
à
là
[Applaudissements]
à